massimo nava bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation tôt ce matin
sur rtl france alors on lisait à partir
d'aujourd'hui donc levée des
restrictions en italie qu'est ce qui va
changer
très concrètement est ce qu'on peut dire
que c'est un retour à une vie quasi
normale mais quasi normal oui par
rapport à 100 corps ces corps à passer
par les derrière moi mais il ya encore
de pythie restrictions par exemple
l'obligation de masquer la distance
sociale c'est-à-dire de regroupement né
d'un partir d'aujourd'hui on peut aller
au restaurant le joueur soit on peut
manger et dîner à l'intérieur des restos
la solde des sols intéressant la chose
interdite c'est de céder dans ces mêmes
c'est l'italienne aime beaucoup la danse
mais les discothèques en appétit
compromis c'est-à-dire que dans les
locaux on peut bien boire comme comme
les bars mais on peut pas danser et en
plus il ya des régions qui sont déjà un
couleur blanche et c'est à dire qui et
c'est la presse que la liberté totale
même sens les couvre feux et il ya
encore des régions qui sont encore avec
des petits restrictions mais qui selon
les b d'ici au 15 juin
est ce que pour rentrer dans les
restaurants par exemple dans les salles
de sport
il faudra à l'avenir justifier avec un
pass sanitaire par exemple qu'on n'est
pas contagieux ou qu'on n'a été
vaccinées ce qui est un débat en ce
moment en italie sur la question si mais
c'est un peu les débats qui est un des
tous les roms c'est à dire on imagine la
grinta ce propos tous les citoyennes et
mais il faut compter aussi qu'est en
italie on est à 36 millions de vaccinés
c'est à dire plus de la moitié de la
population d'aujourd'hui et olemps
ouvertes les vaccinations l'oci
des mineurs il ya plus de restrictions
pour un mineur de 15 ans et est
naturellement les mesures d'aidés
prudence c'est à dire reste toujours en
vigueur mais c'est franchement c'est
finalement la vie la vie normale qu'il
est paré prendre un peu c'est la saison
les bons les temps est bon et les
chiffres et surtout son confort tente
parce que en ce moment on a moins des 40
baisser tous confondus et donc il faut
toujours distinguer ces gens qui sont
marque pour les corps vidéo avec l'école
mais en tout cas sont très bas les laits
leur spécialisation en thérapie
intensive sont très bas et surtout le
comptage sont très bas donc
naturellement tout le monde attend de la
reynerie et économique
il ya un certaine faurie les prévisions
sous les dessous la croissance sont très
bons pour l'italie hier les chiffres
donnent un océan arrêt pays de 400 de
pipe
mais naturellement en est on doit être
très prudent parce qu'on sait jamais
s'ils y arrivent quelques variantes vous
avez découvert il ya un instant tu celle
du vietnam mais j'ai été abusée autre
danger à l'horizon
alors vous le disiez à partir de 15 ans
en italie tout le monde peut désormais
se faire vacciner
les italiens vont volontiers se faire
vacciner ou il ya encore des réticences
que le gouvernement doit nous encore
faire des efforts finalement pour bien
demander aux
aux italiens d'aller se faire vacciner
dès restrictions d'aidé disons que sur
le plan idéologique ya pas trop des gens
qui pensent qu'elle va saint-séverin
dangereux
né il ya probablement un problème de
communication parce qu'on a vu que ya
pas mal d un que des personnes âgées qui
en parle qui sont pas encore vaccinés
puces des us des millions d'amis ou
d'ennemis plus ou moins et il ya un
projet de gouvernement de faire une
action d'information des communications
si vous voulez un peu l'impression
surtout vers la population c'est un
ancien du coup vous parliez de la levée
des restrictions qui varient en fonction
des régions ça veut dire quoi
quelles sont les régions finalement il
n'ya presque plus de restrictions
aujourd'hui donc vous savez a mis
l'italie ccc langue des 3es avec des
climats et des situations totalement
différent donc les gouvernements depuis
quelques mois
depuis l'année dernière l'on peut dire a
décidé d'aider différencier les
restrictions selon des couleurs le blanc
cheveux rouges les l'hiver et tout ça
aujourd'hui on a quatre jaunes blanches
qui sont des données totalement libre et
les autres qui sent libre depuis quatre
ans donc partir de cette date à retenir
les quinze jours donc dans deux semaines
sera presque tous libres dans tout
l'état lit et aujourd'hui c'est les
fruits ou lilas blood ça les marques ex
sommes allés les gens qui rôdent la
sardaigne aussi qui accueille en ce
moment en tournée
des infections très très très bas et
donc la situation totalement sous
contrôle
mais il ya encore des poux dans notre
région mais je répète les courses et
presse qu'elle et b sauf les régions qui
sont encore en jeu donc
donc avant 3 heures et on a là les par
la permission pour pour pour aller
manifester les manistes sportive on
comptait aussi qui en italie commence la
prochaine semaine des championnats
européens de foot donc les jambes les
mains avec une jeune joue pas avec une
jauge avec peut être une jauge un nombre
limité de deux supporters oui oui mais
naturellement même pas plus devant sa
bosse en ayant naturellement les ddd des
contrôles comme on a eu est là il ya
quelques semaines pour la finale de la
coupe d'italie entre l'atalante elle a
human tout ce qui était la première fois
après l'hiver il ya eu des ddt respecte
des spectateurs à les stades avec très
très limité et là les bleus les salles
de sport tu là les lieux à le fermer
les knicks et à 6 en persan pour le
moment merci beaucoup
massimo nava pour tous ces précisions je
le rappelle vous êtes éditorialiste au
corriere della serra